kennt ihr diese momente auf reisen in
denen man einfach innehalten muss weil
man das was man sieht einfach viel zu
krass findet egal ob gigantische
wasserfälle bedrohliche lavafelder oder
bizarre felsformationen unsere erde ist
wirklich voll mit einzigartigen und
magischen naturwundern wie der grösste
meteoritenkrater der welt aussieht wo
genau der hitzepol der erde liegt und
noch viele weitere absolut spektakuläre
orte dieser welt jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
der countdown beginnt platz 6 der
hitzepol der erde
wir befinden uns in der ludwig sste im
iran hier befindet sich der hitzepol der
erde und zwar mit rund 70 grad celsius
im jahr 2005 wurde hier mit einem
infrarot radiometer das satelliten aqua
die bodentemperatur ermittelt und ihr
könnt es euch vorstellen
hier ist es wirklich unvorstellbar heiß
und das macht diesen ort zu einem eher
lebensfeindlichen raum doch
forschungsteams haben hier tatsächlich
leben gefunden skorpione zb die sich an
die extremen verhältnisse angepasst
haben sie ernähren sich vom tod genauer
genommen von verirrten zugvögeln die in
der heißen wüstenluft sterben und
einfach vom himmel fallen doch trotzdem
hat dieser ort irgendwie etwas unter
anderem krasse felsformationen die haben
dazu geführt dass die unesco die ludwig
zum weltnaturerbe erklärt hat und auf
der fünf die längste höhle der welt 590
kilometer lang und sehr weit verzweigt
das sind die gigantischen ausmaße der
männer skfm us bundesstaat kentucky das
riesige höhlensystem aber nicht
plötzlich so da sondern hat eine lange
geschichte wohl ein paar millionen jahre
lang haben wassertropfen das
höhlensystem aus dem porösen kalkstein
herausgewaschen entstanden sind zum teil
riesige säle mit stall aktiven und
stalagmiten die mamas cave bildet das
zentrum eines riesigen
naturschutzgebietes eine absolut
magische welt in den höhlen selbst leben
beispielsweise grillen fische und
fledermäuse und auch als christ davon
hinein und an touren teilnehmen
auf der 4 der größte meteoritenkrater
der welt einen durchmesser von knapp 500
kilometern hat der wohl größte methoden
krater der welt der wilkes lampater
lange blieb er uns unter dem eis der
östlichen antarktis verborgen noch immer
nicht zu 100 prozent geklärt ist wie
wilkes land entstanden ist doch es
spricht einiges dafür dass wohl ein
meteorit dafür gesorgt hat
forschungsteams schätzen die größe
dieses methoden auf rund 50 kilometer
zeitpunkt des geschehens war übrigens
vor etwa 200
50 millionen jahren im jahr 2006 zeigt
ein forschungsteam auf der fachkonferenz
der american geophysical union in
baltimore erstmals darstellung zudem
will chris landkarte spekuliert wird
auch dass der gewaltige
meteoriteneinschlag vor 250 millionen
jahren wohl zu einem der größten
massensterben der erde geführt hat und
zudem auch zur entstehung des
australischen kontinents platz 3 der
tiefste canyon der welt hier guckt man
auch besser nicht nach unten auch wenn
die genaue tiefe der schlucht caligari
nepal unbekannt ist steht wohl fest dass
sie die tiefste der welt ist man schätzt
ihre tiefe von 6000 metern
benannt wurde sie genau wie der fluss zu
ihren füßen nach einer hinduistischen
göttin die für die macht der naturkräfte
steht wirklich passen um sie herum gibt
es majestätische berge mehr als 8000
meter hoch die ureinwohner halten diesen
ort der erde für heilig die mutigsten
bringen sammeln auf dem grund der
schlucht die sogenannten salleck maren
stein im wasser
sie sind heilig und in indien sind sie
mehr wert als gold
entstanden sind sie sind sie aus
weichtieren die vor millionen jahren im
fluss lebten heute sind hier auch viele
touristen unterwegs im besten fall immer
mit einem guide der weg durch die
schlucht dauert etwa zwei tage auf der
zwei platz zwei die meisten gewitter im
jahr das jahr hat 365 tage an 15 bis 45
tagen davon etwa gibt es bei uns in
deutschland im jahresdurchschnitt
gewitter je nachdem in welcher region
man sich befindet an den küsten blitzt
und donnert es deutlich weniger als
beispielsweise in der nähe der alten
finde ich kann man aushalten vor allem
wenn man sich vorstellt dass es in der
gewitter hauptstadt der welt ganze 322
tage im jahr gewitter gibt andersherum
gerechnet also 43 tage pro jahr an denen
es nicht blitzt und donnert
unvorstellbar wenn er also wissen wollen
wohin ja auf gar keinen fall umziehen
sollte merkt euch bongo in indonesien
ihren spitznamen trägt die stadt völlig
zurecht kotaku an übersetzt regen statt
hier ist es nur selten wärmer als 26
grad das in kombination mit dem vielen
wasser und dem fruchtbaren vulkanischen
unten ist ein paradies für die
pflanzenwelt und deswegen ist sogar
weltweit nicht nur für seine vielen
gewittern bekannt sondern auch für
seinen botanischen garten mehr als 6000
pflanzenarten darunter knapp 900
orchideen sorten gibt es hier genauso
wie viele fledermäuse und mehr als 50
verschiedene vogelarten und der platz
eins der kälteste ort der erde wobei es
sind mehrere ich habe mich gleich drei
krasse locations erde für euch wo man
sich besser nicht länger falsch
gekleidet im freien aufhalten sollte zu
einem die russische forschungsstation
wostok in der antarktis die lange als
kältepol der erde galt am 23 juli 1983
wurde hier eine temperatur von minus
89,2 grad celsius gemessen
wenn hier polarer sommer herrscht gibt
es auch mal milde minus 30 grad
herrlich von hier aus sind es noch 1200
87 kilometer zum geografischen südpol
hier hat ein forschungsteam einen ice
kern gebohrt der 420.000 jahre
klimageschichte erzählt 2013 wurde der
kälterekord von rostock allerdings
überboten bzw besser gesagt unterboten
satelliten messungen der nasa zeigen den
kältepol der erde an einem eher drücken
in der nähe von dome argus einer
hochebene der antarktis minus 93,2 grad
celsius wurden hier am 10 august 2010
gemessen
die kasse kälte entstand wodurch die
große höhe über dem meeresspiegel
gepaart mit einem wolkenfreien himmel
67,8 grad celsius - wurden übrigens in
der sibirischen siedlung ya konan
gemessen
es ist der wohl kältesten dauerhaft
bewohnte ort der welt und das krasse
daran im sommer können es in dieser
region auch mal 30 grad und mehr werden
ich selbst habe es mal in sibirien
erlebt innerhalb von zwei wochen wurde
es von -25 plus 40 grad das ist
kontinentales klima wenn ihr kein video
verpassen wollt von clixoom zu den
spektakulären themen aus der
wissenschaft dann drückt mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergessen dich den
genau auf die glocke denn nur dann
verpasst er keine videos wie sensation
interstellare objekt rast durchs
sonnensystem darauf klicken wenn ihr das
sehen wollt das ist ab
sensationell und erstmalig also
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran